this card is broken and I mean that in
both senses of the word and this is all
because Wizards forgot Three Little
Words wheel of potential is a three Mana
sorcery from Modern Horizons 3 that says
you get three energy then you may pay X
energy each player May Exile their hand
and draw X cards if x is seven or more
you may play cards you own exiled this
way until the end of your next turn now
this card was meant to be a fair Wheel
of Fortune effect allowing your
opponents to opt in to the effect if
they wanted versus the classic wheel
effect that forced your opponents to
discard their hand and draw seven which
if you combined with a certain blue
planes Walker left your opponent with
just a single card in hand so what's the
problem with wheel of potential well
players are using it to draw their
entire decks how is that possible you
might ask it all comes down to the
wording of the card let's break it down
in the first line the card says you get
three energy then you may pay X energy
so here you have two choices firstly you
need to select a number for X let's
choose 20 in this example then we have
to choose whether or not we pay that
cost as the card says you may pay X
energy we'll decline to pay the cost in
this case case moving on to the second
line of the card it simply says each
player May Exile their hand and draw X
cards nowhere on the card does it check
whether we paid the energy cost or not
so now as written each player can Exile
their hand and draw 20 cards players are
now looking to use this card to draw
their entire decks and then winning with
F's Oracle or something similar and
before you decide to buy out this card
Matt toac principal magic editor at
Wizards has confirmed that the card is
not intended to work this way and there
is likely an Arata on the way to clear
this up if we look at cards like
localized destruction and jolted awake
they all have a similar wording template
where you gain a certain amount of
energy then you may pay some energy to
amplify and effect both of these cards
however include the words if you do just
adding these three simple words is all
that it would take to fix wheel of
potential now until that time what
happens if someone plays this card in a
tournament do they get to play the card
as it is currently written and draw as
many cards as they want or do they have
to play the card as Wizards intended and
only draw cards equal to the amount of
energy that was paid well this all comes
down to the head judge of the tournament
tournament rule 3.6 card interpretation
says players may not use errors or
omissions in Oracle to abuse the rules
the head judge is the final Authority
for card interpretations and they may
overrule Oracle text if an error is
discovered so if you're playing wheel of
potential in your deck you should check
with the head judge prior to the
tourament to get their final ruling so
how are you playing wheel of potential
as always be sure to like the video If
you learned something and subscribe
because if you don't arada your favorite
card thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you in the next one